what does it take to be the best at what
you do for some it's becoming the face
of your game or an unwavering Devotion
to a single character but in CS go it's
usually the Mastery of the game's
flashiest most iconic and most frag
intensive weapon and there are players
who were born to off the uh pass pushes
from Titan have been called and found
out but that's Kenny s with two and a
third as well
there are also those who molded
themselves to fit the role and the
thunderous playstyle it entails how much
does modesty want to dedicate his life
to this bomb site modesty on catwalk
finds the timing eight seconds if you
can drop the bomb and be everything but
it travels into the site one on two for
Odyssey now it's sacrificial
[Applause]
and he takes simple out of the round to
give it to G2 but among all the
celebrated wielders of Cs Go's Mighty
green there is one notable anomaly oh my
goodness device
Devastation how does he do this the
flick back to Twisters while he even
knows he's coming looks away sees him
and then collater clothes
that's his second collateral of the CT
side the lovely Danish Legend Nikolai
device REITs didn't start out as an
opera by all accounts he doesn't even
wield the big green with the type of
aggression one might expect from such a
superstar and yet device is one of if
not the greatest Opera CS go has ever
seen device waiting for his teammates to
arrive he catches one on the cross
twitch
here device is insane pushing foreign
nonsense
that's ridiculous so what about devices
play style makes him so different from
every other Opera is there a case to be
made on accolades alone that he is
actually the greatest of all time and
now that we haven't seen him play in a
year what can we expect from the Danish
Legend going forward devices had a
really rough game flashed he's gonna get
that shot and it has to feel a little
bit going out middle of the air to take
down Alex another pushing oh
kidding me takes every single one from
nothing to the awpas
all right so before we dive into our boy
deva's opping style I must spit some
lovely sponsored science about the web
browser that was made not only for CS go
lovers such as I but skin degenerates
Opera GX you see thanks to Opera gx's
built-in sidebar Integrations for
Discord twitch and Twitter I can start
feeding skins and just never ever stop
whether I'm creeping The Exchange
monitoring buff Bargains or binging
guilty pleasure videos like sparkles
trade-ups zipple case openings and on a
pixel doing well on a pixel things Opera
gx's seamless pop-out video feature that
activates automatically whenever you
switch Windows keeps the content train
going at all times the home page even
displays the most recent offerings from
your favorite CS go obsessed YouTube
channel what's really cool though is
that Opera GX boasts a super easy to use
control panel that features a CPU RAM
and network limiter allowing me to fine
tune just how many of my computer's
resources I want my browser to use at
any given time this means I can leave my
tabs open while I pug and go from
admiring skins from afar to you using
them at the drop of a hat see what I did
there okay I know that CS go doesn't
technically have hats that's a tf2 thing
but still skins the point is that you
too should try out Opera GX and you can
download it for free from the link in
the description below and to become the
skin degenerate that you know you
already are seriously just try it okay
so our boy needs no introduction Mr Tom
device Cruise the breaker of trophies
the destroyer of monitors and once the
shining star of the most decorated
roster in CS go history an opera who
defied all opting conventions and yet
still managed to accrue 19 MVP awards at
some of the game's most prestigious
tournaments fights are about to come
over devices even here to help out and
now while it is good for one they give
it the respect to get back to the car
that might be their undoing the short
play now from twists oh device reads in
with the flick burning alive in the
collateral in the Flames the ace for
device so how did we get here well
devices CS Journey began back in source
as part of Copenhagen wolves and after a
transition to Global Offensive in 2013 a
merry band of future Danish Superstars
began to gather around him device Dupree
and zipix made their Collective way
through several different teams and
during those years device was known
primarily as a rifler device he should
know he sees Alois while he wants to see
if there's another one he could kill he
spots both let me guess who oh my God
that is insane takes down elements what
a Next Level play but as he was
splitting opping duties with some of the
other players over time it became clear
that device had plenty of potential with
that weapon as well Danny joined us as a
coach in the start of 2016 Sonic at that
point we didn't have a an operator was
kind of fluent me Cajun and Kerrigan
would switch it up between us and he
said we need a we need an over device on
short he will get flashed he'll repeat
his smoke dumb and he finds it too he
gets the headshot after going through a
device are you I want to say it but I'm
not going to are you kidding me and
device close range aw he knows
device now he's short chance nbk is
close here and he's still got 14 seconds
left one clock
device he takes them down and once
astralis came into being in 2016 and
gobbled up tsm's talented Trio of hybrid
players their potential seemed Limitless
but what the team desperately lacked was
structure and a division of Duties that
would allow every player to be an
efficient part of a well-oiled killing
machine so under glaive's tutelage
device put aside the AKs and the m4s and
was designated as astralis's primary
offer now there was definitely a swath
of the fandom that was confused by that
decision but Deva himself was determined
to make the new Arrangement work so he
started off by studying those that came
before him they just don't have that
many grenades so they can't use too many
and again device
against Fallen as Travis are fully in
control of the situation but they have
to hit their shots and so far there's no
like it's happening device though with
that defense two quick kills there he's
gonna be stopping this push before we
can really get going on to that bomb
plan great finish he blows there out of
the vice with that awp with an awp even
at the law oh my God takes down sees the
device oh my God it's on
efforts soon enough device had earned
himself a spot amongst op royalty device
though gotta love the angle but can he
find the heads he can
then there's another one there goes
simple
it's 15 seconds again the bomb needs to
go down they're just running into the
Crosshair and he's delivering every
single dime but device didn't exactly
join the illustrious Superstar or op
Club you see normally opting is about
control an offer exerts pressure on the
map by holding angles and making sure
they cut off the enemy team's oxygen and
keep them where they want them but a
superstar offer is an entirely different
Beast a brilliant hyper-aggressive no
shits-given space maker who defies the
very laws of nature by making risky
plays and hitting no scope flicks that a
regular human could never even hope to
replicate first found twist aggressing
they have to double Peak he's getting
his shot
number one in the game he's done it
again they're cool they're flashy and
everyone wants to be
best offers are essentially the lead
singers of the Cs go world doesn't
matter what my opponents are doing I
will take over and control the match but
the very same things that make them
exciting to watch can also make those
opping Mavericks Reckless heavily
dependent on Instinct and at their worst
overly reliant on the strengths of their
weapon and vice
wasn't about that life no no he did
things differently right from the get-go
device that was already down there good
find on the first one quick switch back
over brings out the Safari match score
and he gets the second kill as well balm
falling forward it's Kenny to try and
respond
with fast flick toward Dupree good read
by device Connors go outside and he sort
of rounds you can divide his third kill
flavors trying to stay alive or on the
clock down here knows his uh
Sonic's happy with that one and
rightly so where some offers went with
their gut device
planned somehow sit in my mind that this
is still possible with the awp Cold's
gonna jump across he's got a pretty much
my God I say they surprise me with their
speed he hits a run boost and closes the
round oh my they just wanted to beat the
off and he absolutely destroys them
where the legendary op wielder smashed W
device waited for his moment this should
be their round all the devices in the
back and you can do so much damage from
here you can see you can hide something
follow-up players he gets another one
and astralis a two on Five and they
finish it off where they thought the op
made them Invincible device sharpened
his fundamentals to a needlepoint so
that he could take advantage of any
opportunity no matter how the enemy team
played it I'm just looking for this oh
my God device speaks in towards middle
he won't find that first kill there's no
shortage box on Australis but the vice
he's got to doesn't want to overextend
but he's going to go and try and get the
timing right that's a third for him and
this is a buy run from optic
they have rifles they have utility and
some fights with another one looking for
the ears they're coming towards him the
vice finds all five and that is
absolutely filthy when it came to this
patient methodical playstyle no matter
how basic it seemed to those of us used
to call zeros jumping Ops and the like
device was in a class of his own and
thanks in no small part to his prowess
with the op astralis truly went to the
Stars holding it now and there is it
it's just how to play me it's not gonna
happen
he'll only punish one but it's just
Ariel the five and it's done
[Applause]
they have one goal that's it that's all
they wanted back to back and they've
done it now two versus four an
impossible retake by any standard device
will take down Buster leaving a trend in
advance
[Applause]
as for Big Daddy device he not only won
four majors with his team but also
collected MVP awards in the double
digits and became a solid fixture in
hltv's annual top 20 list but despite
being the most decorated offer out there
he was never really considered to be a
clear number one by the community and it
seemed like most of the pushback came
from people who would compare him to
Natural Born snipers like simple and
xywoo or off monsters like guardian and
Kenny s think of it this way device was
the master of the most basic defensive
opting style out there sure he was
incredible
but was he truly special the thing is
while we were all losing our minds
watching simple highlights the Danish
Opera was busy quietly but reliably
putting up results for his team and
astralis ultimately laid claim to the
greatest era in the history of
competitive CS go and now for the first
time ever at home
astrology
and for the first time in history the
best of all [__] time unfortunately
all good things come to an end the
online era made short work of astralis's
dominance and Scattered its core with
Device eventually moving over to ninjas
in pajamas I sleep in
one
King time bro device leaves astralis to
nip in
through the move
moves best a cool head on his shoulders
oh no not that I meant the device was
still a consistent reliable and
impactful sniper even against his old
team this gets hot now for device
take a chance and device manages his
angles to Perfection but then in
December of 2021 citing mental health
struggles and personal issues device
took an extended leave of absence and we
haven't seen him since
oh right except of course that he went
back to astralis I mean by it's a basic
compared to seriously
but all the fans that were waiting to
see a strawless device back in Action
were left disappointed when the org
announced that the Opera wouldn't be a
part of any on stage matches until 2023
and look we know that there's a lot of
talk about device not earning his keep
but let's not forget that he was never
one to jump into anything without proper
preparation his entire career has been
built around playing in a way that
meshed well with the rest of his roster
and it takes a lot of time and practice
to get there I know that the
expectations from you guys are really
high they're higher from myself as well
and I know I can live up to them I'm not
worrying too much about the future right
now as I said it's just amazing to be
here and the love from the fans is
amazing so when device does eventually
return to the server should we all be
expecting him to shoot straight to the
top of the rankings well obviously we
can't say for sure what we can say is
that device is undeniably
One of a Kind hell the guy hasn't played
in a year and was still named the number
two player of the decade right behind
the goat himself device didn't make CS
go history by producing the craziest
highlights instead he's an amazing
player that you can actually aspire to
emulate a superstar who somehow managed
to stay Within Reach of an average CS go
enjoyer's understanding of the game all
while winning some of its biggest
tournaments there was never anyone quite
like device before him and by the looks
of it there is no one fit to replace him
anytime soon
[Applause]
that guy
goats in the house
hey everyone thank you thank you for
watching the video but before you head
off I just wanted to give you a quick
friendly little reminder to please
download Opera GX for free using the
link below you can thank me later